blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman it took 50 days but joe biden and
democrats have finally passed their 1.9
trillion dollar covid relief build this
is the third relief
bill yeah since the start of the
pandemic
the house passed a version of the bill
previously
then the senate over the weekend passed
a slightly different version
that's the version which yesterday the
house of representatives
passed making this a done deal with joe
biden's imminent
signature the money will start going out
soon here is the moment that the bill
passed in the house of representatives
yesterday
on this vote the a's are 220
the nays are 211
the motion is adopted
[Applause]
section of motion
now you will note that the bill passed
with 220 democratic
yes votes one democrat voting no
and all republicans who voted voting
no not a single republican voted for the
coveted relief bill in the senate
not a single republican voted for the
coveted relief bill in the house of
representatives
75 percent of the country which means
tens of millions of republican voters 75
percent of the country
supports the bill and yet not one
republican voting in favor who
exactly are republicans representing
because clearly they are not
representing their own constituents
but let's focus on what is in the bill
there's the part for individuals and
then there's the part
for state governments and organizations
for individuals
there will be cash payments up to
fourteen hundred dollars for people
earning up to eighty thousand dollars or
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
for single parents
or a hundred and sixty thousand dollars
for couples now to get the full 1400
the income limit is 75k per person
it will start phasing out but you get
something all the way up to 80
000 as an individual 120 000 if you are
a single parent and 160 000 in income
for couples dependent college students
and dependent older relatives also count
here that was not the case in previous
bills enhanced unemployment
is part of this 300 per week of extra
unemployment above and beyond what your
state offers if you are unemployed that
is extended through the 6th
of september and then up to 10
200 of unemployment benefits
received in 2020 are tax-free
for household incomes up to 150 000
in general um unemployment benefits are
taxable income
subject to your total family's household
income
in general you pay taxes on unemployment
income if you earn 140
000 a year in income because that is um
a tax bracket at which you pay taxes in
this particular case
up to 10 200 of unemployment benefits
from last year would be tax-free
assuming your household income is under
a hundred and fifty thousand
the child tax credit is being increased
up to three thousand dollars per child
and thirty six hundred dollars for kids
five years of age and under
and the limit of the age limit for the
child tax credit also being increased
from 16 to 17
which will include many additional
children so there's a few other things
for individuals that's the bulk of what
has been passed for individuals maybe
like you depending on your financial and
family situation
and then at the larger level the bill
also includes among other things
350 billion dollars for state local and
tribal
governments for pandemic response and
reaction
10 billion dollars for critical state
infrastructure
14 billion dollars for vaccine
distribution very important
130 billion dollars for primary and
secondary schools
very important and this will come up
again later schools that want to open
but they need money in order to be able
to do the things that the cdc
has designated should be done for
schools to open safely
30 billion dollars for transit agencies
uh also very much affected by low
ridership as a result of the pandemic
and 45 billion dollars in rental utility
and mortgage
assistance so it took 50 days
it's 1400 dollars totaling two thousand
if you include the stimulus from six
months ago rather than two thousand
dollars doesn't include the fifteen
dollar minimum wage
but republicans wanted to pass nothing
and we have this ongoing question will
republicans be held accountable by
voters electorally
nearly two years from now in 2022
i believe the answer is no even though
75 percent of the country wants the bill
and not a single republican voted for it
um
voters have short memories quite frankly
that that's basically what it is
i even think that if the 2020 election
had been
in 2021 even in november of 2021 i think
things will have been better enough
that donald trump's disastrous handling
of the pandemic might not actually have
seen him removed from office
that's how short i believe voter
memories are particularly
republicans who go back very quickly to
these sort of reflexive and meaningless
meaningless anti-left
talking points but that is what is in
the bill we expect money to start going
out
possibly within 48 hours of joe biden's
signature
which is imminent maybe even happening
today maybe it will already have
happened even
by the time you listen to today's show
or watch this
clip so listen to this insanity so
the big business in the house of
representatives yesterday was passing
joe biden's
and democrats 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief bill
this happened yesterday it passed
without any republicans voting for it we
already talked about
that okay but that wasn't the end of the
legislative day for the house of
representatives
immediately after passing this bill the
covid relief bill
the house went into debate about a gun
bill and on days when major legislation
is passed
very often you will have more news
stations
and youtube streams around the world
even
streaming what's going on on the floor
of the house of representatives and it
just so happened
that because the house went into debate
over
hr8 hr8 is the bipartisan background
checks act of 2019.
remember that 90 of the country supports
universal background checks
on any gun transaction period but most
republicans in the house
don't support it and because people
around the world
after the vote on covet relief were
still watching the house proceedings
i started getting email from viewers i
got an email from a viewer in belgium
saying david did you see that insanity
that lauren bobert said about guns on
the floor of the house
a viewer in the uk wrote to me and said
david
did you see congressman madison
cawthorne
saying come take my guns on the floor of
the house
so i checked it out and it is truly the
stuff of horrors
the world cannot believe how ridiculous
a large portion of our country and our
elected officials are
on the topic of guns let's look at some
examples
here is completely vapid trumpian
republican congressman madison cawthorne
telling the speaker
i know you want my guns well try to take
them from me
you want my guns i know it we all know
it
well mr speaker you can come and take
them
with that i yield back gentlemen years
back the gentleman from new york
this is one of the foremost legislative
bodies in the united states
and madison cothorn is yelling at the
speaker
to come take my guns the world
is laughing crying horrified
you pick it uh lauren bobert
went to the microphone and argued
against
universal background checks based on a
story
of a man beaten to death outside her
restaurant in colorado
but the story is a lie the man she's
referring to actually
died of a drug overdose not only is this
insane
it's also a lie take a look at this
there was an altercation
outside of my restaurant where a man
was physically beat to death there were
no weapons involved
he was beat to death by another man's
hands i have a lot of young girls who
work in my restaurant
and we needed an equalizer the story is
known to be a lie
so it's a fake story then republican
congressman chip roy
came to the microphone and started
referring to
how he has all these weapons but
he's not going to tell the government
what weapons he has
defiant in principled speech take a look
texans
americans the government is never going
to know
what weapons i own let me be clear about
that
it's not going to happen uh you know
peop people all over the world see that
and they ask
rightly what the hell is wrong
with the united states of america well
these people are what's wrong
then republican congressman thomas
massey
also argued against universal background
checks
on the basis of a hard-to-follow
hypothetical story
about the victim of domestic violence
who needs a gun to make
it through the night i challenge you
follow this hypothetical story how many
of those hundred and twelve thousand
were prosecuted for that crime of trying
to acquire that gun
according to the doj 12.
1 2 12 in a year
who were the other 100 000 imagine
just imagine now that you're the victim
of an abusive relationship and after
five years you've summoned the courage
and the resources
to separate from that relationship but
things have escalated
and now you've decided it's time to
acquire the means to protect you
and your children so you go to the gun
store and you try to buy a gun
the clerk presses the computer button it
says denied
you asked the clerk why was it denied i
don't know this happens
sometimes maybe you had a similar name
to somebody else in the database
you can't buy a gun today tomorrow next
week not ever
you've been denied so you go to a friend
friend you've known for a long time your
friend says i'd like to help you
you say well i don't know if i'm going
to make it through the night the friend
says i'd like to help you
but don't you know hr8 passed and it was
signed by the president
i can't spend a year in a cage good luck
tonight
now what's extra dumb about that story
actually there's a bunch of stuff that's
extra dumb about that story first of all
maybe the person he's describing should
call the police if they think they might
not make it through the night
unless they have the imaginary gun in
the hypothetical shootout
but the problem that congressman massey
brings up
someone might be wrongly denied a gun
because their name
matches that of someone who actually
can't own a gun
whether background checks are universal
or not we already have some background
checks like the
the name confusion could happen
regardless of whether the background
checks are universal or not it's a very
strange example to argue
we shouldn't that's an argument for no
background checks
at all we already have some background
checks not really an argument against
making them universal
so absolutely incredible and the world
doesn't get it the world doesn't
why is it so embarrassing here in the
united states
these are deep cultural educational
uh religious in some cases issues
they are economic issues as well in fact
that shouldn't be written off there is
an economic component
to what we are seeing here but we have
some of the most
radical people we've ever had in the
house of representatives
and they really have some serious
problems personal problems no doubt
uh but also these are just the last
people that we should have making law so
another humiliating day globally for the
united states brought to you this time
by the likes of lauren beaubert and
madison cawthorne and some of these
other people let me know what you think
when you see these rants on the floor of
the house
and then remember friday march 26th
one day huge membership special we had a
tough
february from the standpoint of
memberships
we are trying to recover i'm getting so
wound up i just punched my mic
we are trying to recover and so friday
march 26th we will be doing a mass
mailing to everybody on our newsletter
you can sign up at davidpakman.com for
the newsletter
with a one day really powerful i mean
really powerful membership special i
would love for you to be one of the
people
that gets on the newsletter and signs up
on march 26th alright we'll take a quick
break
and be back right after this the david
pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our show is funded primarily by members
who sign up at joinpackman.com i would
love for you to be
one of those folks go to joinpackman.com
grab a membership get the daily bonus
show
and in fact actually let's get right
into reddit uh reddit threads because
one of them we're going to dig into in
detail on the
bonus show you can join the david pakman
show subreddit
davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
nearly 30 000 of our viewers have and
the
discussions happening there are
compelling and interesting and
respectful
importantly to say the least couple of
posts i want to signal
a user named joachim
rafi says why does pacman keep making
misleading statements about the wall
in his video gensaki saki jeez gen saki
destroys trump in 48 seconds at 32
seconds pakman says now it's really
important to remember
that even though donald trump didn't
build the wall during his presidency he
would regularly claim that he built it
and that the imaginary wall
was responsible for record low document
undocumented crossing
this is wrong and it isn't the first
time pakman said stuff like this
the wiki page says the us built new
barriers along 455 miles
49 miles of which previously had no
barrier
going on to say you can believe as i do
trump is a scumbag
and it's a good thing he's gone but
uh why is pacman painting himself into a
corner on this topic
guys um trump promised to build a wall
across the entire u.s mexico border by
the end of his first term
that that was the promise trump added 49
miles
okay if adding 49 miles
to a bear to a border that's 2 000 miles
counts as building the wall then i have
a bridge to sell you
if this is your critique of the program
this is probably not the show for you
um but very very strange allegations
another post from rico reckless says
are the cuomo allegations intended to
distract from the nursing home scandal
or are the democrats and establishment
using cuomo as the scapegoat
now that biden is in office and there's
no longer a shot at cuomo running
against trump
i don't the second part i think is a no
and i don't think anyone is organized
enough nor
is it clear to me that pushing
sexual assault allegations against cuomo
helps him by distracting from the
nursing home scandal it's just not clear
to me at all
uh the right in fact has seized more
on the um uh on the sexual assault
scandal
even though arguably um it's
it's not better for cuomo that the right
sees on that so it's
it's very nebulous to me that this would
be some kind of strategy i think to me
it's more what was
mentioned in the comments which is when
it rains it pours
and that uh it's just things uh thing
a lot of different things coming out
against andrew cuomo i have no reason to
think
uh nor have i seen evidence that the
democratic party is organized enough
to say oh the nursing home thing is bad
let's now bring to the forefront
sexual assault allegations to take
attention away from that i think both
are potentially hugely damaging to cuomo
and we'll just have to
wait and see and then also interest on
the subreddit
about our former i don't know if he's a
former friend of the show he's been on
the show
milo yiannopoulos is now declaring that
he is
ex-gay he believes that he has
successfully
gone through conversion therapy and is
no longer a gay man
if you don't know who milo yiannopoulos
is congratulations i actually envy you
but we have dealt with a lot of these
ex-gay
advocates on the show in the past and we
know milo
so we're going to talk about this more
extensively on the bonus show but yes
i am aware of the milo quitting
homosexuality story
and um i i do have a lot to say about it
partially because we've had exchanges
with milo
um and in part because we've also talked
to a lot of the people that advocate for
and even do
supposed ex-gay conversion therapy
wacky dangerous stuff to be clear we'll
talk about that more on the bonus show
but feel free to join the discussion
on the subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t okay
this is uh i don't know if this is
surprising or it's not surprising
but we have another audio leak of donald
trump
pressuring georgia officials to find him
the votes that he needs
donald trump's call to the investigator
came several days before the call
with georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger
you'll remember in the past we had
leaked audio of trump on the phone with
raffensberger and others
saying i just need 11 780 votes
this new audio is from a different call
where it was a few days prior to the
raffensberger call
donald trump is on the phone with
francis watson
who's the chief investigator in the
georgia
secretary of state's office we are going
to listen to it i'm realizing i don't
even have my headphone in so let me put
that in so i can listen to it along with
you
uh and i'm getting all of my cables all
wound up here let's take a listen
together
all right new call okay new call
let's uh take a listen to this uh here
we go
and uh let's make sure we aren't muted
and off we go all right
let's take a listen it's very
interesting so i won florida in a record
number ohio and a record texas center
record
right alabama by 40 40 points
and i won everything but georgia and i
you know and i won georgia i know that
by a lot and i won jojo by a lot
he says people know it and
you know something happened there i mean
something bad happened and
i hope you enjoyed that that because if
you
you know i hope you're going back in two
years as opposed to just checking
you know one against the other because
that would just be sort of
a a signature check that didn't mean
anything but
if you go back two years and if you can
get to fulton
you're gonna find things that are gonna
be unbelievable the dishonesty
that we've heard from them right you
know just good sources
really good sources fulton does the
mother lode you know as the expression
goes
fulton county right well mr president
i don't want to speak right yeah i i i i
appreciate your comments and and i i i
can assure you that
our team and the gbi that we're only
interested in
in the truth and and finding you know
finding the information that's based on
the facts and
you know we we we've been working um 12
16 hour days
and you know we're working through trump
likes that we're
working for what exactly is not clear
but do it and
um so i can assure you that and
i do appreciate you calling i know that
you're a very very busy very important
man and and i'm very honored that you
called
and you know i'm quite important what
you're doing quite um
quite frankly i i i'm shocked and that
you
you would take time to to do that but
well he's trying to steal an election
right i mean
this is his last he thinks he needs this
i'm very appreciative
he thinks you're great and you know it's
just you have the most important job in
the country right now because
if we win georgia first of all if we win
you're gonna have two wins
they're not gonna win right now you know
they're down because
the people of georgia are so angry at
what happened to me they know i won
one by hundreds of thousands of votes so
so now trump is not even claim
remember later it seems that between
this call and the next call
he he goes he here he believes he won by
hundreds of thousands and maybe he even
thinks that there would be
something done by these officials to
give him such a big win
within days clearly his perspective has
changed because he's just talking about
i just need eleven thousand eleven seven
eighty
and his expectations are tempered by the
next call
and alabama you know where they go
because i won uh south carolina in a
record
alabama and a record florida and a
record imagine calling an official in
georgia and just bragging about your
wins in other states as if that has
anything to do with what
this woman's job is here i want florida
by six or seven hundred thousand
votes i think he only won florida by a
couple hundred thousand like everything
is a lie an exaggeration
and with all the money they spent you
know you heard all about these guys
going down spending a fortune
and we won texas by a record texas was
won by the biggest
biggest number ever and it you know
it didn't uh it didn't and ohio of
course you know that you know about that
that was one
by nine points he's the president and
he's bragging to a county
uh a state official in georgia
about his margins in other states this
is the president of the united states
calling this person and bragging in this
way
i mean it never made sense
and you know they dropped ballots they
dropped all these ballots
but stacey abrams are really really
terrible
i mean just a terrible thing registering
people to vote getting people out it's
horrible what she did
i will say this if it went home i mean
hopefully
this will show because if you go back
two years or four years you're gonna see
it's a totally different signature but
but hopefully uh i you know i will
when when the right answer comes out
when you'd give us the right answer
francis which is that i won
people will love you know why you know
they've made it so hard
they will be will say praised
because that's what it's about that
ability to check into
and to make it right because everyone
knows it's wrong there's just no way
you know they had people in georgia for
instance that won
and i was way ahead of them and they won
because of me and i pulled them
they call it coattails right and so this
went on for four more minutes and it's
just more trump insisting he won
and to her credit francis watson doesn't
really concede much
at all we then just have as a reminder
the clips from the previous call
uh which uh with the previous call which
we
actually which took place later the
later call which we learned about some
time ago
here's one clip from that the people of
georgia are angry the people of the
country are angry
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know uh
that you've recalculated because uh
the 2002 36 and absentee ballots i mean
they're all exact numbers that were were
done by accounting firms law firms etc
and even if you cut them in half cut
them in half and cut them in half again
it's more votes than we need
well mr president the challenge that you
have is the data you have is wrong
right say we've recalculated 2200
ballots it's enough for us to win
uh and that was that was brad
raffensberger telling trump that his
data was simply wrong
on that call trump continued making
false uh statements uh trying to
convince them to find votes claiming he
won by hundreds of thousands
bringing up more conspiracy theories i
won this election by hundreds of
thousands of votes
there's no way i lost georgia there's no
way we won by hundreds of thousands of
votes
i'm just going by small numbers when you
add them up there many times the eleven
thousand but
but i won that state by hundreds of
thousands of us
now do you think it's possible that they
shredded
ballots in fulton county because that's
what the rumor is
and also that dominion took out machines
that dominion is really moving fast to
get rid of their
machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal this is ryan
germany no dominion has not
um moved any machinery out of fulton
county we're having no but no but
but if they move have they have they
moved
the inner parts of the machines and
replaced them with other parts
no he sure ryan
i'm sure i'm sure mr president what
about what about
the uh what about the ballots the
shredding of the ballasts have they been
shredding ballots
no the only investigation that we have
into that they have not been shredding
any ballots
um there was an issue in cobb county
where they were doing normal uh
you know office threatening getting rid
of old stuff and we investigated that
so trump just desperately grasping at
straws
and then remember that in the end even
if he had somehow flipped georgia it
wouldn't have made a difference
because it would not have been enough
electoral votes just one more clip from
the old phone call
which happened after the one we learned
about today trump suggesting that this
is actually bad for georgia officials
they might be liable if they don't find
a way for trump to get the win
the ballots are corrupt and you're going
to find that they are which is totally
illegal it's it's
it's more illegal for you than it is for
them because you know what they did and
you're not reporting it that's a
you know that's a criminal that's a
criminal offense
and and you know you can't let that
happen that's that's a big risk
to you and to ryan your lawyer that's a
big risk
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
uh 11 780
votes so trump there kind of implicitly
threatening the lawyers and officials
if you let it happen you could be you
could be criminally liable
so a totally criminal bully president
another recording
from another conversation coming out
almost two months post trump leaving
office
what will we know in another month what
will we know in a month after that
what we are learning is that the
authoritarians who tried to overthrow
the election were
far more brazen than we previously
thought i don't think we've come even
close
to hearing it all yet and when all is
said and done
the biggest evidence is probably yet to
come
they're getting access to emails and
texts which will give us the context and
planning like this call these two calls
they don't just happen there's likely a
paper trail
about how this call came to be and about
the intentions for these calls
and we may eventually learn about that
we'll have more coverage of this on the
show instagram at david pakman show and
make sure you're
following me on instagram at
david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
nicole pearl roth who's an award-winning
cyber security journalist for the new
york times and also
author of this is how they tell me the
world ends the cyber weapons arms race
it's so great to have you on i
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me david
so let let's just start kind of at the
top level i think
a lot of people who are aware of a cyber
threat
and about the priority that this has
become for so many governments may not
really understand what a cyber attack
might actually mean
sort of for the average person you might
have a vague idea about
could you shut down a water system for
example or paralyze
an electricity grid or something like
that what do we mean by cyber attack
what are the types of things that could
be done
so for a long time people's real
experience with
cyber attacks was really just the theft
of their personal data or maybe their
credit card
information and there was no real
repercussions there you know you might
have to deal with identity theft if it
got really gnarly
but for the most part your bank would
probably pay you back
if any money was stolen from your
account or credit card information that
kind of thing
the problem is that these days we have
rolled so much software
into our critical infrastructure like
the power grid
like our nuclear plants like our water
treatment facilities and wastewater
treatment plants
that all of that those access points
can be the target for a cyber attack and
in fact we are seeing
every year more nation-state hackers but
also low-level
cyber criminals target these systems and
so the attack that we really fear
uh would be an attack that took out
power and potentially contaminated the
water and actually it would look
a lot like what we just witnessed in
texas
a few weeks ago when the power went out
you know the water supply was
contaminated and
in the event of a cyber attack which you
could use
cyber means to take out the power and
contaminate the water and we've seen
russia do that in ukraine and
we just saw an attempt to contaminate
the water supply in a small town in
florida the other week
fortunately it was caught but the
problem is with the cyber attack there's
also the possibility
that hackers could keep those systems
down
and when we've run studies here in the
united states to see
how resilient our critical
infrastructure is to cyber tech
some of those simulations have showed
that it could be years before
people were able to bring those systems
back online so i think we're a little
bit better than we were when those
simulations were done but there's a real
threat
of a cyber attack on on the grid
so when it comes to the kind of identity
theft
credit card theft stuff that many of us
have dealt with all of a sudden
i had a period where like uber and door
dash charges were showing up on my
credit card and it was the annoyance
type stuff
it seems the motivation of the
individual is basically to get free
stuff to get a free
uh free takeout or a free uber ride or
whatever the case may be
when we start talking about things like
shutting down a power grid contaminating
water etcetera
it's see correct me if i'm wrong it
seems we're talking about a fork
that is more malicious for the sake of
being malicious
of making a political point of of making
an attack
that may be more against an institution
or a country or an organization
are those these two forks in terms of
motivations or is it more complicated
than that
well i think you're right i mean a lot
of the attacks we have seen
on critical infrastructure has been
messaging
when russia shut off the power in
ukraine
first in 2015 and then in 2016
they only did it for a few hours and i
really believe that that was to send a
message
to sort of seed doubt in ukrainian's
mind that their new government
had things under control you know it was
really political messaging and sort of
hanging this threat over the population
that russia could turn off the power at
the flip of a switch
other attacks have had different
motivations we caught iran
rifling around the controls at a dam in
the united states
fortunately it was the wrong dam we have
two bowman dams
one of them holds back a tsunami's worth
of water in
oregon and the other holds back a
babbling brook in
new york and they got into the one that
holds back a babbling brook and it was
under repair so it wasn't an actual
threat
but you know who knows what the message
was there
i think it was probably just some sort
of experimentation to see if they could
get into these systems
in case they needed to one day you know
unleash the locks
at that dam um and that's more of what
we're starting to see we're starting to
see
nation state hackers get into these
critical infrastructure systems
not necessarily because they want to do
something immediately
but because we're all planning for some
kind of geopolitical trigger
where we might need to be in a position
to turn off the lights or unleash the
locks at a dam or contaminate the water
supply
but you know each of these attacks
essentially enshrines critical
infrastructure as a legitimate
target for a cyber attack and at the end
of the day it's civilian populations
who would suffer the results of those
attacks so it's yeah
more dangerous this so this is one of my
questions about how this fits
into warfare more broadly because you
know one of the things that's happened
over the last 10 to 15 years is
we we've heard more about and it
actually has moved in the direction of
the idea of a war that's like a boots on
the ground war the likes of which
you know certainly the first gulf war to
a degree the 2003 iraq war
things are moving away from that drone
warfare is certainly part of it but also
so is cyber warfare
but a foreign power for example shutting
off electricity in a large part of the
united states we understand the chaos
that it will create
we understand the damage it can do but
how would it fit into
a broader war in the sense of what would
it be
part of trying to accomplish for the
foreign power that does it i i'm
guessing it's not shut the power off so
they can
steal florida from us and make it part
of some other country there must be
what would be the goal or how would it
fit in yeah it's a really good question
and it's an important question because
you don't want to over hype
the threat right um but it is the
reality
that russia has been targeting our grid
for several years now a few years ago
the department of homeland security
published a screenshot that literally
showed russian hackers inside
our power plants with their fingers on
the switches that could turn
off the lights so we know that they have
gotten into these systems which begs the
question what are they doing there
you know at what point will they see
some kind of incentive or motivation to
turn off the lights
right i do think that this is
all battlefield preparation for
some future event whether it's you know
a declaration of war
and this would be one element of that
warfare
turning off the lights or shutting off
the communication systems
in the event that geopolitical tensions
got so
heated that one of these countries felt
the need to do so
we have been hacking into russia's grid
i broke that story with my colleague
david singer a couple years ago
partly as retaliation somewhat for the
election but also for russia's
acts and incursions of our own grid but
we've been doing it more
as mutually assured destruction i was
going to say
yeah i was going to say it reminds me of
like during nuclear
weapon development a lot of people say
what is the circumstance where we would
ever use even 10 of these nukes like
what is that situation and it becomes
this conversation of well you know if
they did it
we would we would need to be in a
position to do it and being in a
position to do it would disincentivize
them from doing it
it it has a sort of similar feel as you
mentioned that
yes it is our attempt at mutually
assured destruction
in the digital age um the problem is
that nuclear analogies really don't fit
so neatly in cyber
um you know for one this is all code
right
we're attacking these systems with code
um there's a low
barrier to entry you know if we hack a
system
it is entirely possible for that attack
to be discovered
for those methods to be discovered for
that code to be picked up
and reverse engineered and retrofitted
and used back on
us and in cyber what we've noticed over
the last 10 years
is that people learn a lot from their
adversary
you know we pulled off an attack with
israel
on iran's nuclear plant where we broke
into
their nuclear facility natan's nuclear
facility
we dispatched code that jumped from
their microsoft windows systems
into their industrial controllers and we
eventually used that code to spin their
uranium centrifuges
out of control or slowed them down and
we ultimately destroyed
a thousand of their centrifuges no one
has pulled off a cyber attack
that level of sophistication since but
um you know what our adversaries have
learned is they don't need to have the
sophistication
of that attack to do damage a couple
years after that attack
we saw iran hit saudi aramco world's
largest oil company saudi arabia
right with an attack that just used
rudimentary code to
wipe out the data on their systems and
replace it with an image of a burning
american flag
and so we're all sort of learning after
each other and
each attack has sort of build off the
capabilities of the last
and unlike nuclear where you need
fissile material
to drop a bomb right in cyber you just
need a laptop and someone with the
skills
and increasingly you can purchase those
skills
and code and capabilities off a gray
market
so it's really unregulated space
it is getting more and more dangerous
particularly as we digitize more of our
infrastructure
and the thing i think people don't
realize is that you know
america might still be the greatest
offensive player in this realm
like i said no one has pulled off
anything close to the attack we pulled
off
on iran more than 10 years ago but
we are also the most targeted we have
more nation states and cyber criminals
lined up
at our borders at our systems knocking
on the door
getting in in a lot of cases and
planting back doors
and we're the most vulnerable in a lot
of cases because we are so
wired much more so than adversaries like
north korea and iran etc
so on that note i mean in the limited
time we have left
the reaction of some might be well we've
got to pull all of our we have to go
backwards technologically
we have to get a lot of stuff that's
currently networked off of networks uh
uh
silo things etc in in most instances
that's that's not really a solution to
problems
would it be the wrong the wrong reaction
to this
no i mean i think we do need to step
back and think harder about the defense
of these systems
eighty percent of america's critical
infrastructure is owned and maintained
by private companies and any attempt
to sort of legislate that they have
better security
has has always failed lobbyists have
always watered it down so any
attempt to secure our critical
infrastructure has come in the form of
an executive order
first under obama and then there was one
under trump
um but really you know these are all
just setting voluntary standards for
these critical infrastructure owners to
up their security and
unfortunately a lot of these systems are
owned by small medium-sized businesses
local municipal systems
that simply don't have the security
budgets or resources of a pg e
say here in california so they have to
rely on this outside network of
contractors and supervisors
and the fact that they have to let those
people in remotely creates an
opportunity for hackers
so what do we do you know if we're not
going to legislate that these
companies have to up their security what
do you do and i think
one of the things that we need to start
talking about is
creating better market incentives for
these companies to up their security
you know giving tax credits maybe to
companies who
use two-factor authentication and have
all of their software up to date
and pass with flying colors on a
penetration testing
exam um or perhaps it's time to exact
penalties on companies who are not
updating and patching their systems and
allowing anyone to remote in
so i do actually think it's a really
important question to ask ourselves okay
if we're not going to let the government
into these private systems
if we're going to rely on the market
well the market has
always led us down a path of further
vulnerability because
security has no return return on
investment
yeah it's the deepwater horizon the 500
000
valve if you install it everywhere you
protect but
it's unlikely you'll need it everywhere
and then they install it nowhere at all
that's such a great analogy i hadn't
thought of that but that is the perfect
analogy and so we really need to have
these conversations around
how to lock up these systems um and
you know there's been some conversations
about should we have a digital geneva
convention
should we set some kind of international
norms of behavior
where we would agree not to hack
russia's power grid and they would agree
not to hack ours or
hospitals or elections the problem is
we the united states will never agree to
those norms
because one we are still we still have a
huge offensive advantage
but also too we don't trust that our
adversaries would hold to those
agreements
because they outsource many of their
attacks
to cyber criminals to
contractors and front companies the
attacks that we conduct out of the
united states come out of the pentagon
cyber command or maybe the nsa
if it's espionage or the other
intelligence agencies
we don't rely on some you know security
engineer at google
and tap him on the shoulder at night and
say tonight you're working with us
we just don't have that ability or
plausible deniability so we worry that
if we ever agree to these norms
that these other countries would just
sort of say well we won't do it
but they would outsource those attacks
right we don't we don't really want to
commit not to doing it and we wouldn't
believe that their commitment would be
would be trustworthy they may believe
the exact same
about us as well and it makes it a very
complicated uh situation we've been
speaking with nicole
pearl roth who is a cyber security
journalist for the new york times
the book is this is how they tell me the
world ends the cyber weapons arms race
nicole really appreciate your time today
thank you so much for having me
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon as little as one dollar
per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this has to be seen to be believed and
it's almost
as sad as it is unbelievable
a donald trump has forced his way back
onto twitter he's tweeting
by writing letters which are then
published and retweeted by his kids and
friends
this is a former president folks you
might recall that donald trump was
banned
from twitter some time ago for
constantly
persistently endlessly stubbornly
inciting violence and telling
lies about the 2020 election results he
is now putting out statements
through his save america pac which are
often duplicates from things he's
posting to
gab some kind of right wing social
network
and it's all on donald trump letterhead
but these are now tweets he's he is
publishing letters that are just tweets
yesterday trump put one out that says
statement by donald
j trump 45th president of the united
states wouldn't it be fantastic
if the legendary herschel walker ran for
the united states senate in georgia
he would be unstoppable just like he was
when he played for the georgia bulldogs
and in the nfl he is also a great person
run herschel run
that's a tweet in written letter
form he figured out how to force his way
back onto twitter i believe this is a
ban evasion but we'll talk about that
and then donald trump jr reposts it
and before you know it trump's tweeting
writing tweet length letters
posted by his family to twitter he then
sends
a much crazier one and this is
i almost feel bad for the guy this is
one of the saddest
statements i've ever seen from a
president trump clearly triggered by
yesterday's announcement from joe biden
that the u.s has secured an additional
100 million doses of the jnj vaccine
uh donald trump quote tweeting sort of
writing a letter where he says
this is it's almost sad quote
i hope everyone remembers when they're
getting the kovid 19
often referred to as the china virus
vaccine
that if i wasn't president you wouldn't
be getting that beautiful shot
for five years at best and probably
wouldn't be getting it at all
i hope everyone remembers isn't there
something
really sad about that these really are
tweets now i don't you know what can
twitter really do
can twitter ban statements written
statements from the former president no
i don't think so i don't even think that
they should but
if we're honest this does violate the
spirit of the ban i mean it is
ban evasion and it's all
so strange and desperate and i know that
some are saying
nobody should even mention that trump is
doing this you're amplifying it by
sharing it
this isn't about amplifying the content
this is about how
donald trump has figured out a way in
his desperation to be back on twitter
he's figured out a way to circumvent the
van the ban
it's about desperation it's about tech
regulation
it's about so many other things that
we've been talking about on this show
but some aspect of this is also just
really really sad i imagine trump
sitting there at mar-a-lago
eating his kfc and drinking his diets
and his malts as he likes to drink
um and watching joe biden show up with
as we saw yesterday the jnj ceo
and the merc ceo and announcing
everybody's going to be able to get a
vaccine by the end of we're going to
have enough vaccines for everybody by
the end of may not necessarily everyone
will get one by then it's gonna take
some time to inject them
we're doing a hundred a million dose
deal
we may have so many doses we're gonna be
giving them to other countries and trump
wants to tweet
but he's off twitter so this is what he
is now doing it's both
delusional but also a little bit sad in
some way
i'm not going to shed any tears though
if that's what you're waiting for that's
the latest from trump forcing his way
de facto back on twitter yesterday i
talked
generally about the white house press
corps
apparent inability or lack of desire to
ask serious questions of white house
press secretary
jen saki we talked yesterday about the
dogs and cats questions from the
previous day
today i want to drill into a two-minute
exchange
between jen saki and fox news reporter
peter ducey
now i'm going to admit up front because
i think it's more interesting
if i'm honest with you there is a kernel
of a good topic here that peter tries to
bring up
but he's so blinded by his desperation
to be hysterical and histrionic uh and
and make the exchange
as confrontational and dramatic as
possible
that what could be an interesting topic
gets lost in the noise of hyperbole
i won't say more let's just hear the
question and then we'll talk about it
cdc tells
these migrant shelter facilities that
they can be at full capacity
if they are careful about covid many of
them do
but when the cdc tells schools that they
can open
in person at full capacity many of them
don't
is there a school in particular that you
have as an example that didn't
do that are most schools in this country
at full capacity with
in-person learning so the question in
general
is fair but he asks it in a completely
dishonest deceptive and needlessly
dramatic way
he says how can the same cdc be saying
child migrant detention facilities at
the border can be open at full capacity
but schools can't open at full capacity
because it's too dangerous
the fair part of this question is that
in both schools and migrant centers
both have the potential to have a lot of
kids crowded together
and we have a pandemic why can one be
open and the other one can't
that's a perfectly fair kernel of a
question
now the circumstances of course are
completely different kids in schools
most of them have parents most of the
possibility of remote learning not all i
understand
there's communication between schools
and parents and kids there's an
apparatus where the relationship is
completely different
the migrant children at the border you
can't say
we're gonna do remote border facilities
where you will be with your parents and
via zoom you will join the border
facility like it doesn't even compute it
doesn't
make any sense the circumstances are
completely different
in both cases the cdc has put out
guidelines and recommendations
the reason the guidelines aren't the
same is because the scenarios are
completely different and what's possible
is completely different but peter is
desperate to have these gotcha moments
and so what
is actually a good topic gets lost
to the hyperbole and histrionic
questions let's let's continue with it
are there a specific school though that
is not following the cdc guidelines of
of implementing the mitigation steps so
they can reopen
the cdc is saying schools you can be at
every school can be at full capacity
the cdc guideline the cdc guidelines
just to be clear because i think this is
very important to be very clear and
specific on
they they gave eight mitigation steps
that schools can take
to safely reopen a number of schools
have actually recently
reopened schools in washington d.c some
have schools in many districts across
the country
but each school district needs to make
the decision about whether they are
able to take those mitigation steps the
president has also been clear
some of these school districts need
additional funding there's 160 billion
dollars
in this package that he's going to sign
into law later this week secretary of
education will be quite focused on
working with school districts to
help them reopen but more school
districts are reopening
more kids are in classrooms every single
day so jen
saki points out lots of schools aren't
open because they haven't met the
guidelines
some schools haven't met the guidelines
because they can't afford to meet the
guidelines without the coveted relief
money
which was finally passed yesterday so
many schools
are soon going to have the money to do
what the cdc recommends
and to get open like that's substantive
that's that's
important this is separate from
what makes sense now you know we we've
talked about
does it make sense or not to open
schools does the immigration policy make
sense or not
i just want to focus on the hypocrisy of
peter ducey
that's created when in reality these are
very different
circumstances he's blinded by his
unquenchable thirst for drama
maybe his desire to impress his dad
who's also a fox news host but
uh he he keeps going and then he changes
his approach
a little bit but since they are not all
back from an administration
position or from your perspective have
the border patrol
unions and the hhs unions been easier to
work with than
the teachers unions i i think that's a
little bit of mixing
different circumstances i would say that
it's children
all in tight quarters uh
i mean a classroom but not quite funny
not quite so jen sake's opinion
of whether it's easier to work with
border patrol or teachers unions is
really irrelevant
but eventually peter gets to how he
should have started
which is that both the border migrant
centers and the schools are children
in tight quarters that's true that's the
similarity
what is different such that we have
different guidelines that's a fair
starting point
it's not the way he went about it here's
just the last few moments of this
i i would say that let's let's take a
responsible approach to the two issues
okay
one is schools reopening there's been
eight mitigation steps that have been
announced by the cdc to implement right
every school district is going to work
to implement those
on a timeline that is uh they can
effectively do
many school districts are reopening
right many are reopening every single
week and
day and week right that is a different
circumstance
than what we are seeing at the border so
bottom line
peter has a kernel of relevance wrapped
in a veneer of gotcha
and gensake often handles parts of it
well
and then gets a little flustered for
other parts she's
she's mostly good at appearing calm even
if we get the sense that she's
frustrated she does
sort of have to be like the patient mom
when the kids are misbehaving
but the important part is that this is
the culture war
sort of framing where the context for
everything is
this is hostility towards law
enforcement
and deference to teachers unions for
example like that's that's one
cultural element of why this is framed
in such hyperbolic
terms or it's a purported left-wing
double standard when the truth is
listen circumstances are different in a
school versus
in a child migrant facility and peter
ducey will likely keep doing this for as
long as fox news keeps him in the
briefing room because my
my instinct is the fox news viewer sees
this
and says look at that he's holding gen
saki to account
and jen saki's doing a terrible job of
answering these questions that's my
instinct of how the right
sees peter ducey's participation in this
and to the extent that they like it
i would expect if places like oan and
newsmax can get back in the press
briefing room
i would expect them to do this but
scaled up like 10 notches
we have a voice speaking of double
standards we have a voicemail number
which you can call anytime it's 2192
david p
yesterday we talked about the republican
double standard between
the trump sexual assault allegations and
the andrew cuomo sexual assault
allegations this caller
rightly points out it goes well beyond
just that as an example
hi david um you raised a good point
recently
about the double standard regarding um
improper sexual allegations against uh
men in government
and how you know trump actually got off
very easily but why is
cuomo being lambasted so severely and my
question is also about supreme court
justices right
clearance thomas who had very serious
allegations
lodged against him by um
a subordinate employee continues to be
on the bench for many years and then
also
i'm trying to remember the name of the
one that trump appointed
brett kavanaugh i think his name is
brent i'm not i don't remember at the
moment but
that was also a very you know many very
very serious allegations of sexual
impropriety against him
but yet he continues on the supreme
court
our highest court in the nation our
court of justice
absolutely the double stan i mean listen
we can talk about the double standard
with bill clinton
we can talk about the double standard
with you know anthony weiner who is
widely denounced and abandoned by
democrats
uh you could talk about the al franken
situation certainly the clarence thomas
situation is a good one it is
endless endless endless hypocrisy and
i'm glad to have the uh
the additional examples we have a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about
milo yiannopoulos saying that he's been
converted out of homosexuality
we will talk about idaho ending
powerball because they fear foreign
participation
and we will talk about arkansas passing
a near total abortion ban and what this
could mean for roe v wade
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show get the bonus show
every day not weekends every weekday
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman